meine Damen und Herren wir schauen jetzt
noch mal in den Bundestag heute um 14
Uhr kommt da die afd-fraktion zu ihrer
konstituierenden Sitzung zusammen immer
noch für uns dabei ist er hat schärfer
was steht denn da auf der Tagesordnung
das waren wir gleiche direkt mal weiter
und es kommt nämlich bei der
afd-fraktion wie bei vielen anderen auch
sowohl die alten als auch die neuen
Abgeordneten heute zusammen die
Konstituierung einer Bundestagsfraktion
wird ja unterschiedlich gehandhabt von
den verschiedenen Fraktionen als auch zu
unterschiedlichen Zeiten gehandhabt
worden in dieser Woche dass die AFD erst
heute zusammenkommt hat auch damit zu
tun dass diese konstituierenden
Fraktionssitzungen im Plenarsaal
stattfinden also auch wird die AFD im
Plenarsaal des Deutschen Bundestages
zusammenkommen und da waren verschiedene
Zeiten geblockt aber heute ist sie
endlich dran 14 Uhr und bei uns ist
Bernd Baumann der bisherige erste
parlamentarische Geschäftsführer der
afd-bundestagsfraktion und ich frage mal
direkt mutmaßlich auch der neue und
nächste möglich ist alles nachdem ich
vorgreifen aber sie stellen sich zur
Wahl das ist ja entscheidende Punkt und
dann nehme ich mal an dass sie dann auch
die nötigen Stimmen kriegen von ihren
Abgeordneten was steht sonst noch auf
dem Programm ich habe es gerade schon
gesagt die Fraktionen handhaben das
unterschiedlich also manche haben
beispielsweise nur ihre Vorsitzenden
gewählt bei ihnen habe ich hier eben
schon angedeutet steht das ganze
Programm an wir wollen den Vorstand neu
wählen haben dazu auch zwei Tage
angesetzt heute und morgen wählen das
durch und dann wird die Arbeitsordnung
beschlossen wie die anderen Fraktion das
auch machen und dann sind wir
geschäftsfähig es gab Diskussionen wenn
ich das richtig mitbekommen habe aber
die Wahlen zum Fraktionsvorsitz Alice
Weidel und Tino kropalla wollten quasi
im Doppelpack antreten ist das
inzwischen geregelt weil es gab ja da
auch glaube ich Widerstand dagegen in
welchen Parteien gibt es nicht gegen
irgendwas irgendwie Widerstände gucken
sobald die CDU was sie gerade macht da
wird hoch und runter diskutiert und die
Leute demontiert das machen wir nicht
aber es ist trotzdem eine freie Wahl die
nur propala und Alice Weidel haben
erklärt sie wollen zusammen antreten und
da werden wir gleich sehen wie die
Fraktion sich dazu verhält da wird es
Diskussion geben da wird abgestimmt und
da geht das dann ganz normalen
demokratischen Gang wie wir das ja seit
vier Jahren vernünftigerweise machen
auch in der letzten Legislatur war unser
Vorstand ja stabil das wollte ich ja nur
wissen ob es mittlerweile deine Einigung
im Vorfeld gegeben hat die
Unionsfraktion hat ja im Grunde vor der
weniger ihrer gestrigen Sitzung dann
schon mal die den Kompromisse erarbeitet
der dann in der Fraktion abgestimmt
worden ist aber da haben sie noch
Diskussionen wenn ich das richtig
verstanden habe gibt es jetzt keine
Vorabsprachen soweit ich das weiß wir
gehen gleich in die Sitzung rein und
dann werden die Kandidaten sich
präsentieren und dann wird gewählt was
ist ihr Votum sondern können sollen sie
zusammen antreten oder lieber einzeln
ach das ist geheime Abstimmung ich das
waren zwei Spitzen Leute die können
zusammen antreten die können getrennt
antreten da sind zwei starke Leute das
soll die Fraktion entscheiden würde dann
aber zu lassen von Alexander gauland
gehen wenn ich das richtig verstehe ne
weil mehr als zwei Fraktionsvorsitzende
können ja auch sie nicht gebrauchen
sozusagen der hat ja seine Pflicht
sozusagen erfüllt hat das vier Jahre
lang gemacht hat das sehr gut gemacht
die Fraktion zusammengehalten und jetzt
wird neu gewählt jetzt werden die
Vorsitzende neu bestimmt und auch die
ganze Fraktion wird der Vorstand wird
neu gewählt wissen sie oder können sie
uns berichten von anderen Kandidaten die
den Fraktionsvorsitz zu übernehmen
wollen da die sicher selber melden im
Vorfeld so einer Wahl und sich das
überlegen oder nicht überlegen kann ich
dazu gar nicht sagen was die Vorsitzende
angeht schon mal gar nicht für den
Vorstand gibt es mehrere Kandidaten noch
verschiedensten Positionen ist ja auch
gut so dass man dann sieht wer das
meiste Vertrauen unter den Abgeordneten
hat dass du hier eine starke stabile
Fraktionsvorstand kriegen wir wieder
vier Jahre durchhält sie haben vier
Abgeordnete weniger als zu Beginn der
vergangenen Legislaturperiode 30 Prozent
sind neue wie gut kennen Sie die schon
den eine oder anderen kenne ich die
anderen noch nicht aber beim letzten Mal
waren alle neu 84 von damals 93
Abgeordneten an keinerlei
parlamentarische Erfahrung das ist ganz
anders wir haben jetzt Apparat wir haben
erfahrene Abgeordnete wir haben
referentenassistenten Sekretärin der
ganz Apparat den die anderen auch haben
haben wir jetzt auch bei zwei bei der
letzten Wahl viel schlimmer da begannen
wir von nichts
und sie haben sogar noch ein paar übrig
jetzt dadurch das sind die paar
Abgeordnete weniger sind sie haben einen
Frauenanteil von 13%, das ist der mit
Abstand geringster von allen
Bundestagsfraktionen sind sie zufrieden
damit oder sagen Sie es geht halt nicht
anders es geht nicht anders will ich
nicht sagen aber das ist halt bei der
AFD so wir positionieren uns gegen den
Links grünen Mainstream auf den Straßen
five dan harter Wind wenn man Kandidat
werden will da wird schon mal das
Schaufensterscheibe eingeschlagen ich
hatte drei farbanschläge auf mein Haus
ein Brandanschlag meine Frau hat auch
Angst ich bin ein bisschen robuster
möglicherweise schreckt das äh die eine
oder andere Damen sich dann so zu
positionieren für uns haben ja eh das
Problem durch die diabolisierung Weiten
teils dass viele vom Rand zurufen super
was ihr macht aber wir können nicht in
euren Kreis treten weil wir haben Angst
wir sind Beamte dann werden wir verfolgt
dann verlieren wir unseren Job dann
machen wir keine Karrieren mehr das ist
ja flächendecken in der Republik und
trotzdem haben wir es ja geschafft
wieder über 10% zu landen weil das was
ich jetzt geschildert haben kommt in
Einzelfällen vor ist sicher auch zu
verurteilen ist aber doch nicht die
Regel und ist doch nicht das
Tagesgeschäft das kann doch nicht der
Grund dafür dass sie so niedrigen
Frauenanteil haben in ihrer Partei und
in der Fraktion Hamburg haben wir
Wahlkampf gehabt da hat der NDR bei uns
angerufen er möchte eine Aufnahme machen
von einem wahlplakat der AFD was da
drauf steht er hat kein unzerstörtes
gefunden in Hamburg ob wir noch wissen
wo ein unzerstörtes steht und wie die
Plakate angegriffen werden wir natürlich
auch die Plakate Aufsteller angegriffen
da sind Leute im Krankenhaus das ist
wirklich ein harter Job die Antifa in
Hamburg bringt aber Tausende auf die
Straße das ist ein brutaler Job ist sie
sind weiten Teil eine Medien überhaupt
nicht angekommen was hier los ist in der
Republik ich habe wir konnten nicht eine
einzige Wahlkampfveranstaltung machen
weil die Werte alle bedroht wurden
sofort so dass Sie gesagt haben würden
wir gerne machen können wenn ich nicht
eine einzige Wahlveranstaltung im ganzen
Bundesland Hamburg war möglich das ist
ihre Perspektive ich habe viele viele
die letzten Wochen sehr aufmerksam auch
durch dieses Berlin hier gegangen und
immer wieder geguckt auch in dem Bezirk
und in den Kiez in dem ich wohne und
hatte ehrlich gesagt wenig zerstörte AFD
Plakate gesehen aber deswegen in Berlin
darf man sie ganz nach oben in Hamburg
müssen sie auf den Boden stellen und da
werden sie zerstört gut wir können das
wahrscheinlich ewig weiter diskutieren
weil ich bin ja ja bitte immer eine
Frage der Perspektive auch
Fakten er will immer bestreiten mit
ihnen ich bin nicht ganz sicher ob das
tatsächlich der ausschlaggebende Grund
dafür ist das findet ja nur alle vier
Jahre für ein Bundestagswahl statt
irgendwie das was ich jetzt beschrieben
haben im Landtagswahlen sind für alle
vier bis fünf Jahre ob das tatsächlich
der Grund ist warum relativ wenig Frauen
irgendwie sich irgendwie als
parlamentarium bewerben die weil die die
da sind haben ja offensichtlich auch
keine Angst sie müssen ja versuchen die
wenigen die sozusagen keine Angst haben
die da irgendwie durchkommen sie müssen
sich bevor sie ins Parlament in den
Bundestag kommen ja vorher positionieren
dann müssen sie in dem Ortsteil mal
Bezirksvorstand werden und sich
sozusagen in der Partei dann hoch dienen
bekannt machen sie müssen sozusagen
diese Ochsentour auch bei uns
mittlerweile machen und dann müssen Sie
auch raus auf die Stände und diese
ganzen Dinge machen und das ist wirklich
für Frauen nicht schön aber aber der
innerparteiliche Bewerbungsprozess wenn
ich irgendwo hin will der findet ja
innerparteilich statt und nicht auf Wahl
stellen die bereit sind sozusagen in
diesen Kreis zu treten der ist begrenzt
das ist wirklich ein großes ein großes
Problem für uns gut nehmen wir so zur
Kenntnis sie sind eine kleinere Fraktion
nach fraktionsgröße jetzt Platz fünf
statt drei
haben damit auch den
oppositionsführerschaft verloren in
dieser Legislaturperiode also eine
deutlich andere Ausgangslage als 2017
sie sind allerdings haben sie werbe
gerade beschrieben organisatorisch jetzt
deutlich besser aufgestellt
welche Konsequenzen ziehen Sie ausgeben
dass sie jetzt nicht mehr die ersten
sein werden die nach einem Kanzler reden
beispielsweise vorher waren wir die
ersten andere waren die zweiten oder
dritten die stellen jetzt die Regierung
heißen FDP oder grüne das ist kein
gravierender Nachteil man kann auch
dadurch aussteigen und sich
positionieren es geht ihm unsere Themen
nicht wann wir reden an welcher Stelle
sondern dass unsere Reden zu den Themen
sind die die anderen nicht bespielen
innere Sicherheit Kriminalität offene
Grenzen diese Energiewende Politik die
sozusagen weite Teile bevölkerungsstrang
Richtung der Industrie dass wir diese
Themen bespielen darauf kommt es an ob
wir jetzt erster oder zweiter reden du
lieber Gott haben sie jetzt aber auch
wieder ein Alleinstellungsmerkmal wenn
sie sagen die anderen besprechen das und
diskutieren das nicht die anderen nee
die anderen unsere Themen sind sozusagen
wären keine Themen im Plenum wenn wir
nicht da wären und darauf kommt es an
dass diese Themen bespielt werden ich
selbst habe beispielsweise die erste
Rede zu Clans gehalten 2018 hat vorher
nie ein Mensch gemacht den
Bundestagswahl kein Thema und solche
Themen bespielen wir das machen wir das
bringen wir zu Debatte als einzige und
das ist nicht so wichtig ob das ein
erster zweiter oder dritter Stelle in
der in der Debatten Ablauf ist welche
Themen wollen Sie denn setzen in der
kommenden Legislaturperiode das sind die
gleichen Kernthemen die ungelöst sehen
dass er es ist ja ein Dauerthema wenn
sie sozusagen auf die Zahlen gucken es
kommen immer noch beispielsweise jetzt
nur Thema Migration 10 bis 15.000 jeden
Monat über unsere Grenzen größtenteils
ohne Pass aus Orient und Afrika das ist
eine Großstadt im Jahr wir haben immer
noch das Problem mit der Energiewende
ich selbst habe vor zehn Jahren mal eine
Wärmepumpe mir eingebaut im Garten um
sozusagen nichts mehr zu verbrennen kann
Öl und Gas weil das modern ist das
kostet Strom 17 Cent jetzt kostet der 34
Cent die Wärmepumpe ist ein Wahnsinn das
macht überhaupt keinen Sinn diese ganze
Energiepolitik macht so keinen Sinn das
ist ein zweites Thema Klima Energie und
natürlich wenn uns junge Leute am Stand
begegnet sind die sagen wie kann ich
meine Rente kriegen Null und negativ
ziehen das ist doch nicht möglich auch
da haben wir recht behalten Euro und EZB
und sozusagen ist knallt an die Wand
gefahren das sind unsere Kernthemen nach
wie vor wenn diese Defizite so deutlich
da sind und die anderen das nicht
hinreichend bearbeiten warum haben Sie
da nicht deutlich besser abgeschnitten
bei dieser Bundestagswahl sondern sogar
minimal verloren 2,3% sind jetzt nicht
die Welt aber sind doch weniger als vor
vier Jahren Morgen hat das gelegen weil
wir einfach diesen großen links grünen
Mainstream gegen uns haben teilweise in
den Medien großen Teil sogar will jetzt
nicht sozusagen
ich habe auch vernünftige Journalisten
irgendwie kennengelernt aber viele haben
schon einen argen beides wenn Sie über
uns berichten das ist schon eine
Einseitigkeit wo mir manchmal sich die
Haare Kreuz und ich habe immer
Journalismus gelernt darf ich mal ganz
kurz an dieser ich unterrichte ja
aber wenn das stimmt mit diesem mit
diesem links grünen Mainstream oder wie
auch immer sie das nennt wie erklären
sie denn da bitteschön die Ergebnisse in
Sachsen Thüringen und
Sachsen-Anhalt abgeschnitten haben weil
da müsste dann ja da auch wirken wenn
das so was Mainstream das Wort sagt es
ja gilt ja quasi überall also da müsste
da ja da müsste es ja da genauso sein
die Menschen da sind anders sozialisiert
die haben eine ganz andere Kritik die
haben ganz anderes Misstrauen von vorne
rein ging
die gucken die aber die Vertrauen den
nicht mehr weil die schon mal
öffentliche Medien kennengelernt haben
in ihrer Vita wo man zwischen den Zeilen
lesen musste wo schon mal manipulativ
sozusagen berichtet wurde da sind die
vorsichtiger da ist der Einfluss der
Massenmedien sozusagen begrenzter das
ist ganz klar die Sache ich muss noch
mal sagen es gibt auch vernünftige
Journalisten auch selbst sind natürlich
rechtlichen immer wieder kennengelernt
aber ich habe auch oft einen starken
Bayes sozusagen entgegengenommen und
ihre Frage war ja unsere Wahlergebnisse
wenn die Leute wirklich wüssten was
unsere Ziele sind und wie wir sind dann
hätten wir wahrscheinlich besser ergeben
aber das Übertragen wir eins zu eins
wenn wir im Bundestag übertragen
entweder wird gar nichts dran gemacht
sondern dass es wirklich ungekürzt
ungeschürftiger dran also dass man kann
das schon alles sehr genau das kann man
gucken aber auch da gucken die Leute das
Online sich an ich habe jetzt im
Wahlkampf bei Hamburg 1 sind alle
Spitzenkandidaten sozusagen interviewt
worden nacheinander und da hat der der
Grünen Spitzenkandidat 500 Leute die
sich auf Youtube angeguckt haben die
anderen haben so zwischen 100 und 400
und der Kandidat der AFD Bernd Baumann
hat fast 140.000 da sehen sie wie die
Leute suchen im Netz sozusagen nach
reden nach originalen nach sozusagen
authentischen Grundlagen wie der
Wahlkampf sozusagen funktioniert ich
glaube bei Youtube lassen Sie die
Gegenreden zu ihren Reden im Bundestag
dann auch immer weg ne
das machen die Leute selber die Klingen
dass sie als was sie als AFD posten und
publishen irgendwie sind hier
normalerweise die Gegenreden nicht dabei
sondern ausschließlich die Reden ihre
Abgeordneten alle alle Abgeordneten
aller Fraktionen posten ihre Reden ja
und die werden für sich von den Lesern
aufgerufen von den Zuschauern und die
gucken sich an was Sie interessiert und
was nicht aber das immer ist immer eine
Rede für sich es gibt auch bei CDU und
FDP reden auf YouTube keine
Zusammenschnitte verschiedener
gegnerischer reden das entscheidet eben
das entscheidet eben der Wähler selbst
weil gegen Argumente wollen die dann
auch nicht hören die anderen
öffentlich-rechtlichen genug und den
anderen Leitmedien na dann gleicht es
sich ja doch aus dann ist ja doch nicht
so schlimm mit den Mädels ist gleicht
sich nicht ganz aus und das sind die
fehlende 2 %
hoch interessante Erklärung Herr Baumann
eigentlich nicht die einzige Erklärung
andere das kann doch dazu das praktisch
CDU und SPD jetzt Kopf an Kopf gewesen
sind und viele Konservative sich gedacht
haben bevor das Land ganz unter die
Räuber Gerät will ich lieber noch mal
die CDU damit sie sozusagen nicht ganz
untergeht das kann natürlich auch noch
Grund gewesen warum die ein oder andere
Stimme die früher AFD gewählt hat jetzt
noch mal CDU widerwillig mit
zusammengebissene 10 CDU gewählt hat
aber auch 9% verloren die müssen ja auch
irgendwo gewesen sein Wahlergebnisse
spiegeln immer auch die Gesamtlage einer
Partei wieder behaupte ich jetzt mal
also nicht nur die öffentliche
Wahrnehmung und was du wie Sie es gerade
beschrieben haben am Montag in der
Bundespressekonferenz waren die
Konflikte zwischen den
Parteivorsitzenden Meuthen und den
Spitzenkandidaten Weidel und Propeller
deutlich spürbar wann wird es da eine
Einigung geben eine Verständigung oder
eine Lösung es gibt auch da Diskussion
unterschiedliche Standpunkte wie in
anderen Fraktion auch wenn ich mir
angucke was die CDU gerade aufführt
gestern und vorgestern wie die
aufeinander sozusagen eindreschen und
uneinig sind gerade was die Spitze
angeht dann sind wir da noch
weisenknaben wenn die drei sozusagen
nebeneinander sitzen und die
Wahlergebnisse etwas unterschiedlich
Gewichten also weiter Propeller und
Meuthen verhalten sich im Grunde wie die
von ihnen sogenannten Altparteien im
Grunde nicht anders nee deshalb gibt das
sagen sie das sage ich überhaupt nein
das hat mit Altparteien doch nicht sie
sagen es gibt den anderen Fraktionen in
den anderen Parteien auch solche
Diskussionen das ist das Prinzip von
Parteien das ist Flügel gibt die
einstellen sich mehr so auf und die
anderen Stellen sich mehr so auf das ist
eine Bandbreite gibt es in allen
Parteien linken Flügel rechten Flügel
und dass die vielleicht auch in der
Interpretation von Wahlergebnissen nicht
genau zu identischen Ergebnis kommen
sondern unterschiedliche Draufsichten
haben finde ich ganz okay und das tragen
sie öffentlich auf der Bühne aus vor 4
Jahren ist eben die damalige
Parteivorsitzende abhanden gekommen
irgendwie unmittelbar nach der
bundeswirtswahl das was die drei gezeigt
haben dass sie gar nicht miteinander
können war ja auch deutlich Stürmer das
kann ja auch nicht das kann aber auch
nicht Sinn der Sache sein oder sie haben
einfach die unterschiedlichen
Standpunkte dargelegt das war nicht in
völliger Deckung ist aber auch okay
welchem Standpunkt neigen sie denn Ihnen
zu dass das ganze irgendwie ein bisschen
vergurkte Wahl und ein vergurkter
Wahlkampf war oder das irgendwie das
eigentlich alles gut gelaufen ist oder
wie Frau Weidel sagt ich lass mir dieses
Ergebnis nicht kaputt reden es ist nicht
alles gut gelaufen das was wir
eingangsdiskutierten die sozusagen
rangsalierung von außen und das gar
nicht in Gang kommen von Wahlkampf ich
sage ja im Bundesland Hamburg nicht eine
einzige Wahlveranstaltung war möglich um
die Wähler einzuladen und Unternehmen so
und so weiter das zweite ist dass wir
intern auch sozusagen verschiedene
Ansatzpunkte haben das war nicht so
geschlossen wie es hätte sein können die
SPD hat das diesmal vorgemacht eine
große Geschlossenheit das war bei uns
nicht sozusagen überall so das kann man
im Nachhinein durchaus konzidieren es
war auch nicht nur AFD sozusagen typisch
aber wir reden gerade über die AFD
deswegen wollen wir da auch dabei
bleiben was muss passieren ihrer Meinung
nachher um das die Partei wieder
geschlossen eingeschlossenes Bild abgibt
und kein zerstritten
ist es nicht das waren es
unterschiedliche Sichtweisen auf das
Wahlergebnis das kann man haben wir
nicht weiß machen dass irgendwie alles
Weidel und der Parteivorsitzende morgen
ein Herz und eine Seele sind wo gibt es
in welcher Fraktion gibt es das denn sie
können nicht verlangen dass alle ein
Herz und einer Seele sie ist ist Laschet
und Söder ist das ein Herz und eine eine
Seele und die nun definitiv auch nicht
und essen
überhaupt keine weiß man auch dass das
keine die haben ihn als
Parteivorsitzenden verhindert haben sie
sich jetzt haben sie das gleich fertig
diesen Begriff verwendet aber sie wissen
genau was ich meine dass sie dass sie im
Grunde ja auch auf offener Bühne
austragen dass sie nicht miteinander
können und möglicherweise auch gar nicht
miteinander arbeiten wollen nein das
haben sie nicht sie haben
unterschiedliche Ansichten betont wie
das Wahlergebnis zu bewerten ist Herr
Meuthen sieht das eher kritisch indem er
betont menschenskind wir hätten
eigentlich mehr gewinnen können wenn wir
mehr westthemen mehr
Themen beispielsweise gespielt hätten
und die anderen haben sehr nee wir haben
sozusagen Kernthemen gespielt und haben
da groß gepunktet vor allem im Osten
beides ist für sicher richtig man muss
das nur zusammenführen dann braucht man
ich glaube ich habe sie zeitlich über
gebührt jetzt hier
befragt entweder ihr Mitarbeiter zeigt
mir schon irgendwie das noch anderes zu
tun gibt ich danke Ihnen trotzdem dass
sie hier gewesen sind heute Morgen und
auch geblieben sind bis zum Ende dieses
Gespräch vielen Dank immer bis zum Ende
weiß ich doch sonst würden sie ja gar
nicht anfragen bitte Herr Baumann vielen
Dank noch mal Fraktionssitzung um 14 Uhr
und dann wird gewählt ab 16:30 Uhr wenn
ich es richtig Erinnerung habe
beginnt der zweite Teil zuerst den also
neue zusammen und dann beginnt der
zweite Teil und dann geht es auch zu den
Wahlen und dann erwarten wir danach die
Bestellung Namen der dann gewählten
Fraktionsvorsitzenden wer auch immer das
dann sein will vielen Dank dafür danke
mir Herr Baumann danke Ihnen